[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau de l'année
d'interdire pour une émission consacrée
à la lutte des classes avec thomas
porcher membres du collectif des
économistes atterrés qui publie un
nouveau livre chez fayard les délaissés
c'est sous titré comment transformer un
bloc divisé en force majoritaire bonjour
thomas porcher
de quoi est il composé ce bloc divisé
dont vous souhaitez faire une force
majoritaire bonjour frédéric taddeï et
pas écouter ce ce bloc divisée c'est en
fait 85 % de la population française que
je regroupe en divers catégories dans le
livre mais qui subissent tous finalement
à différents niveaux
le modèle économique tel qu'on le
connaît aujourd'hui qui est basé sur le
triptyque mondialisation
financiarisation de l'économie et
austérité budgétaire
donc vous avez différentes catégories
vous avez les cadres par exemple qui qui
le subissent beaucoup moins que les
gilet jaune ou que les habitants des
quartiers populaires anc les
agriculteurs mais qui globalement
subissent ce modèle économique on voit
bien aujourd'hui les les salaires
finalement stable depuis une quinzaine
d'années dans lé cadre vous faites pas
de +5 vous retrouver dans un deux pièces
ou un studio va sur paris on a beau vous
dire en fait partie des 20 % les plus
élevées en termes de revenus vous ne le
voyez pas dans votre vie de tous les
jours et à l'autre bout fait un habitant
des territoires vous avez vu les
services publics
quittez votre territoire vous avez des
entreprises partir s'installer dans des
endroits où la manoeuvre était moins
cher et donc donc vous vivez de plein
fouet
finalement ce modèle économique donc
tout le monde à différents niveaux et
victime du modèle sauf une petite partie
qui en profite
il serait intéressant que aujourd'hui
ces gens en prennent conscience plutôt
que de s'opposer avec cette idée qu'on
ne peut pas remettre en cause la
répartition des richesses mais qu'il
faut déshabiller paul pour habiller
jacques
c'est à dire des habits un autre délai
c'est pour mieux habillées 1 1 autre
délaissés et donc la lutte des classes
ne doit plus être horizontale mais elle
doit être clairement verticale sur une
petite petite partie de la population
qui profitent depuis 30 ans de ce modèle
économique
il ya deux citations en épigraphe de ce
livre deux citations sur la ville
décrite classes l'une et de warren
buffet est on la connaît elle a été
souvent répété l'autre et de tarnac karl
marx qui explique qu'on ne constituent
une classe que si on lutte contre une
autre
classe sinon au sein de la même classe
on est des ennemis et des concurrents
c'est le cas aujourd'hui d'après vous
tout à fait c'est le cas et tout ça est
instrumentalisé en grosse partie des
partis politiques mais aussi par des
intellectuels médiatiques qui qui aime
bien opposer les libéraux par exemple m
opposer les fonctionnaires et les
salariés du privé ils avaient opposé les
travailleurs à bas salaires aux chômeurs
et puis vous avez de l'autre côté le
front national qui aiment opposé les
habitants des territoires aux habitants
des banlieues ou les personnes issues de
l'immigration aux personnes française
100% on va dire il y compris d'origine
et qui vivent dans la campagne alors
qu'en réalité d'un point de vue purement
économique
un habitant de banlieue et un habitant
des territoires a subi de plein fouet
les mêmes effets vous regardez dans le
93 à aulnay les usines ont fermé elles
se sont installées ailleurs au regard
des dents dans l'est dans le nord de la
france c'est exactement la même chose
vous regardez les services publics dans
le 93
ils ferment les uns après les autres
vous regardez dans le nord de la france
est exactement la même chose
la seule différence c'est que les
habitants des banlieues c'est un espèce
de grenier à main d'oeuvre qui sert les
centres villes via notamment maintenant
les hubert des libéraux etc
alors que les habitants des territoires
aux ont été laissés pour compte et on
leur offre un dialogue autour de la
mobilité
formez vous soyez mobile est allé
trouver du travail ailleurs mais les
mêlées mais ces deux personnes que le
front national par exemple va opposer
frontalement sont en réalité victime du
système économique de la même façon et
devrait en prendre conscience et
s'allier pour remettre en cause le
système plutôt que de s'opposer de cette
manière là thomas dès la première page
de ce livre vous éprouvez le besoin de
raconter que vous avez vous même grandi
dans une cité de banlieue en seine saint
denis dans le 93 que vous n'êtes pas
donc pas loin de ces classes populaires
en dépit de vos diplômes l'économie
c'est un peu comme l'europe c'est aussi
une question de crédibilité si on est si
on appartient à la bourgeoisie on n'est
plus crédible
en tout cas pour tenir un discours sur
la lutte des classes n'ont absolument
pas en réalité ce que j'ai voulu dire
c'est que j'ai pas attendu
contrairement à d'autres peut-être de
faire des études d'économie de rentrer
des données dans les tableurs excel et
de me rendre compte qu'il y avait une
partie de la population qui souffrait or
j'ai vu sept dernières années avec le
soulèvement notamment des gilet jaune
que certains découvraient une france
qu'il ne connaissait absolument pas en
se disant maintien peut-être qu'en fait
il y avait des gens qui subissait la
mondialisation peut-être qu'en fait il y
avait des gens qui subissent l austérité
salariale alors que moi je l'avais
remarqué dès mon plus jeune âge et je
veux dire ce qu'ils ont vécu dans le 93
comme moi à cette époque ont vu des
quartiers entiers se dégrader au même
moment où que les usines fermées et ont
vu comme je le dis dans les premières
pages de mon livre mois des parents de
mes amis il sombré dans l'alcool
certains même jusqu'aux sus il on a vu
un appauvrissement total et une
délinquance augmenter au même moment ces
trente dernières années
et donc voilà je pense que beaucoup de
gens y compris dans les territoires moi
ga pas de 2,2 des territoires mais mes
ou de de ce que certains appellent la
france périphérique mais je pense que
beaucoup de gens ont vu aussi des zones
entières française changé avec la
mondialisation et ont vu leurs
territoires s'appauvrir voilà moi
maintenant je suis toujours surprise
quand je vois par exemple je vais pas
citer de noms mais pour enfants pour en
citer quelques-uns mais les économistes
qui disent bon écoutez en fait moi j'ai
défendu le libère le la mondialisation
le libéralisme je me rends compte
aujourd'hui j'écris un livre en vous en
vous disant que les salariés vont se
révolter un jour aux combis 40 ans
d'austérité
bah ça me fait doucement rire parce
qu'en réalité des gens ça fait 40 ans
qu'ils le vivent dans leur chair ils
n'ont pas besoin de rentrer des données
ou de se rendre compte sur 30 ans sur
une série comme statistique qui avaient
des problèmes non non ils l'ont vécu et
moi c'est ça que vous les rappeler au
début c'est que j'ai pas eu besoin
d'avoir des diplômes qu'on me rende
compte qu'il avait des gens qui
subissait le modèle économique et il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont eu besoin
d'attendre 30 ans on dira ville
peut-être qu'on a été trop loin
ben en fait rapidement les gens se sont
rendu compte dans les territoires et
dans les banlieues qu'on allait trop
loin
votre livre il sur un sujet très proche
dernier livre d'emmanuel todd la lutte
des classes au 21ème siècle emmanuel
todd que j'ai reçues il y a plus
d'ailleurs dans les mêmes conditions
sauf que lui n'était pas par skype
c'était avant le christ dieu coronavirus
alors lui il est pas né dans le 93 il a
grandi à saint germain en laye mais est
ce que vous sentez proche de son analyse
j'ai alors bien sûr code il ya j'ai pas
lu et pour être parfaitement honnête
son dernier livre j'ai vu dans je les ai
vus chez vous je les ai vus dans
différents médias je trouve qu'il ya
toujours quelque chose d'extrêmement
brillant chez tonnes parce qu'il est ils
osent faire bouger les lignes et donc de
ce que j'ai vu en tous les cas j'ai pas
eu encore le temps de lire le livre mais
de ce que j'ai vu sur médias interposés
et je trouve qu'il y avait effectivement
des points où on pouvait se retrouver
notamment dans le déclassement justement
même des classes supérieures comme les
cadres ou gelée vue où il a dit que les
cadres étaient amenés à aller vers le
sort des employés et des ouvriers dans
les années 90 et moi je partage aussi ça
et je pense qu'à un certain nombre
d'autres personnes le partage aussi donc
dans le les analyses de tôtes surtout
jours sont toujours intéressantes et moi
je suis toujours de très près ce qu'il
dit bien sûr vous expliquer dans ce
livre que l'économie est d'abord un
rapport de force entre les classes
sociales mais pas seulement quand on se
partage la richesse également au niveau
du discours au fond et le discours est
une arme
oui oui bien sûr et le disent constater
aujourd'hui vous avez des classes
populaires qui subissent la
mondialisation dans tous les sens qui
suffisent austérité salariale mais qui
vont tenir des discours assez proches de
ceux finalement de l'élite mondialisée
du style quand on veut on peut
le travail c'est quelque chose de très
bien qui vous permettent de devenir
riche fac qui prennent en compte
vraiment il faut plus de liberté faut
payer moins d'impôts etc
c'est à dire quand vous discutez parfois
avec des chauffeurs hubert et vont vous
dire il faut baisser la fiscalité mais
la réalité c'est que lorsqu'il leur
fiscalité est très élevé mais elle est
aussi élevé parce que la plateforme qui
les emploient ne paie pas d'impôts en
france donc la vraie question n'est pas
la question de plus ou moins d'impôts
laquelle la question c'est une question
de justice fiscale
les impôts 20 % d'impôt sur un chauffeur
au beurre c'est énorme quand il sait que
sa patronne en paie pas les charges que
l'on va payer peut-être un appât 30 café
vont être énormes quand ils voient que
juste en face de lui vous avez starbucks
qui n'en paient pas donc donc on est
vraiment sûr voilà sur un problème
plutôt de justice fiscale
que de questions de fiscalité de niveau
de fiscalité
donc vous dire laquelle daily telegraph
non pardon et la fiscalité est un
problème qui est surtout relatif me
semble-t-il avec des gros qui en payent
très peu et qui empêche de moins en
moins je me suis pas reconnu nicolas
sarkozy quand il se présentait en 2012
il s'était rendu compte qu'un certain
nombre d'entreprises ne payez pas
d'impôts il voulait faire un impôt
spécial qui l'avait qualifié l'impôt
total à l'époque donc voyez vous avez du
cac 40 qui ont des pressions fiscales
beaucoup plus faible que certaines pme
et ça c'est un vrai problème et vous
avez aujourd'hui des multinationales qui
ne paient pas d'impôts en france quand
d'autres des petites pme en paix c'est
ça aurait le nerf de la guerre c'est pas
de baisser la fiscalité pour tous
mais en baissant la fiscalité finalement
amazon aura toujours plus davantage
qu'une librairie du coin c'est de faire
en sorte que amazon paye plus d'impôt
que la librairie du coin
vous parlez beaucoup des vainqueurs et
des perdants de du système économique
tel qu'il existe aujourd'hui dans ce
livre est pour vous les vainqueurs dans
le langage des vainqueurs il ya toujours
tout pour convaincre les perdants qu'au
fond ils n'ont que ce qu'ils méritent
ils sont responsables de leur sort
mais pourquoi ils ne le sont pas c'est
pas vous voulez les perdants du système
ne sont pas responsable du fait qu'ils
sont les perdants d'élite du système
mais alors ça voudrait dire que du temps
où les classes populaires ont arraché un
certain nombre de conquêtes sociales à
la bourgeoisie aux possédants
il n'en était pas responsable non
lui à ce moment là c'est à dire que ce
serait la bourgeoisie qui l'aurait
octroie une qui leur auraient octroyé un
certain nombre de droits d'acquis
sociaux comme on les appelle aujourd'hui
par pure générosité puis qu'aujourd'hui
les leur retirerait mais j'ai
l'impression que s'il était responsable
de ses conquêtes sociales si les ont
gagnés en luttant justement ils sont
aussi peut être responsable de les avoir
perdus en une lutte en plus ou en
luttant mal alors ces deux choses
différentes
tu d'accord avec vous que pour avoir des
acquis sociaux il faut entamer un bras
de fer avec le avec le patronat ou avec
les avec les détenteurs en fait des
capitaux ce qu'ont fait les ouvriers est
ce qu on fait même les vigiles et jaune
l'année dernière parce que racontent les
gilets jaunes ont réussi et c'était les
premiers à le faire c'est pas les
syndicats qui l'avait fait ont réussi à
faire reculer macron qui a quand même
lâché 10 milliards donc c'était c'était
une première donc effectivement c'est en
mettant la pression sur les politiques
n'est aussi sûr n'est sûr les dirigeants
qu'on obtient des acquis sociaux et moi
là je pense qu'on est dans une phase
alors le faire on voit déjà tous les
rapports qui ressort au faire travailler
plus les gens revenir sur les congés ou
partie des congés payés les vacances etc
là il va falloir que mais que le
salariat ou clés ou que même délaissé
tiennent le rapport de force
maintenant sur la question de la
réussite sociale de l'ascenseur social
et qu'effectivement le discours des
libéraux c'est de dire que quand on veut
on peut
c'est donc toute une question est
finalement une question de choix
personnel s'ils ont choisi les bonnes
études si on choisit le bon secteur
si on choisit de travailler beaucoup on
a une chance de réussir mais c'est une
fable en réalité c'est une fable parce
que vous avez derrière une capitale
culturelle le capital social et les
statistiques le montrent aujourd'hui
c'est à dire contre un enfant d'ouvrier
vous avez de fortes chances de ne pas
faire de longues études et quand vous
êtes un enfant de cadre vous avez plus
de chance de faire des très longues
études
pourquoi parce que le système est fait
parce qu'ils sont les dominants voiliers
et donc c'est très rare de voir des gens
qui ont une forte ascension sociale et
on va les mettre en avant pour dire
regardez il ya une é ré cancre assis ça
existe des gens qui
oui ça existe mais globalement les
là-dessus là globalement ce que l'on
voit c'est que quand on est fils
d'ouvrier on a plus de chances d'être
ouvrier que quand on est fils de cadre
ou fils de je ne sais je ne sais pas
quel autre métier
ce qu'on appellerait un métier qualifié
et ben on a plus de chances d'avoir le
même le même type de poste donc il ya
clairement des freins donc aujourd'hui
porté un débat uniquement sur l'égalité
des chances c'est un débat qui est pour
moi trop limité il faut aussi qu'il y
ait une égalité de résultats c'est ça
aujourd'hui et donc pour qu'il ait cette
égalité de résultats il va falloir faire
comme pour les acquis sociaux que
certains les premiers concernés les bel
essai exerce une pression politique ou
au mieux place quelqu'un au pouvoir
qu'ils ont choisie qui servira leurs
causes qui servira pas la cause des
instincts coup 10%
il ya de vraies inégalités effectivement
au niveau des études mais elles sont pas
liées à l'argent seulement vous avez des
des acteurs de cinéma qui gagne
énormément d'argent aujourd'hui dont les
enfants ne font pas d'études vous n'en
trouverez jamais ni appeler technique ni
à l'ena ni même en médecine c'est très
très rare encore moins à hec et pourtant
leurs parents gagnent des millions même
chose pour les joueurs de football on
pourrait dire les choix de football
gagne encore plus d'argent que les que
les acteurs de cinéma et vous ne verrez
rarement leurs enfants ailleurs que dans
des centres de sport comme les enfants
d'acteurs d'ailleurs très souvent
deviennent eux mêmes acteurs il ya une
sorte d yahia l'héritage culturel qui
est considérable au fond il vaut mieux
si on veut faire de bonnes études vaut
mieux être fils d'instituteur au fils de
profs que d'être fils de stars de cinéma
oui quand je ne parlais pas que des
études mais vous regardez là vous avez
prêté vraiment du doigt quelque chose
d'assez intéressant c'est vous regardez
aujourd'hui dans le show business chez
les acteurs robin
j'ai rencontré faire de la comptabilité
nous avait beaucoup d'enfants de de gens
connectés même dans les milieux qu'on ne
connaît pas qui ont des grands noms mais
qui travaille comme dans le milieu du
cinéma et donc vous rendez bien compte
qu'il ya là effectivement un capital
culturel à capital social et je dirais
même un capital financier parce que
quand on prend des cours au bout d'un
monde vient très bon qui fait que voilà
vous allez devenir acteur parce que vous
êtes bien n'est pas parce que vous avez
travaillé ou pas parce que vous avez
fait ce qu'il fallait
vous en avez un parfois qui sort comme
ça mais la réalité vaut mieux
aujourd'hui pour être acteur bien n'être
que de bien travailler
par contre pour le football c'est pas la
même chose si votre père est footballeur
et qu'il est très très bon vous vous
allez devoir passer quand même une
compétition et courir même avec tous les
moyens si vous ne courrez pas comme il
faut ce n'est pas l'envié
ce qu'il faut et si vous avez des pieds
carrés et vous tirez pas là où il faut
vous ne serez pas un grand joueur de
foot alors que si vous êtes finalement
un enfant d'acteurs et vous êtes un peu
moyen vous arriverez toujours grâce au
capital social on va dire et culturelles
et l'héritage en fait des connaissances
avec qui tu as mangé quand tu étais
petit ainsi de suite
vous arrivez toujours à avoir des rôles
à droite et à gauche qui n'est pas le
cas pour un joueur de foot hein on en a
jamais vu peut-être le fils de kadhafi
un moment a réussi à jouer alors qu'ils
n'étaient pas très bons mais c'est assez
rare globalement et pour les études pour
les études ce qui est plus pernicieux
c'est qu'on fait comme si c'était comme
le football qu'il y avait des concours
etc
mais ces concours sont faits dans
l'attitude dans tout dans l'actif que
l'on doit avoir au zorro dans la culture
que l'on doit mobiliser dans les
connaissances fin quand vous regardez
moi je me souviens quand j'étais jeune
le concours de sciences pause était une
épreuve de culture générale
une épreuve d'anglais et après une
épreuve de spécialité et ben moi si
j'avais passé le concours de sciences po
je n'aurais pu challenge et un autre
élève qui aurait fait henri iv qui
aurait grandi peut-être aller enfin tu
as fait l'école alsacienne ujica je
n'aurai plus le challenge est que sur la
spécialité sur l'anglais ça c'est encore
quelque chose qui des pansements
d'héritage culturel social des voyages
des cours qu'on a pris des stages qu'on
a fait les colonies de vacances bilingue
et ainsi de suite et le culturel
dépendent également de lait des sorties
en musique vous avez fait des voyages et
intitulé est donc là dessus
quels cas de classes populaires est
complètement perdant alors que soit la
technicité d'une spécialité en économies
ailleurs en droit il peut être changer
tout le monde s'il a été à la fac mais
le concours était fait de sorte que
voilà on reproduisait une élite et les
résultats ont montré dans les
statistiques qui avait été fait à
sciences po c'est que c'était la
reproduction des élites au plus haut
point mais ça touche un point d'intérêt
intéressant tout ça de comparer
notamment le football et le cinéma parce
que souvent les gens rêvent d'une
société du mérite
il est à 6 seulement des terres une
vraie société du mérite mais le problème
de la société du mérite mais il suffit
de regarder le football professionnel ça
c'est une vraie société du mérite
vous l'avez dit vous avez beau être le
fils de zinedine zidane si vous n'êtes
pas bon joueur de football
vous ferez pas carrière et d'ailleurs il
ya très peu de
fils 2 qui ont fait carrière dans le
football le problème c'est que il ya
plein d'enfants qui vont dans les
centres de formation des clubs
et puis il en sort un sur 101 sur s'en
va devenir un footballeur professionnel
et aux autres il reste que les yeux pour
pleurer
dans une société du mérite si vous
n'êtes pas don ou parmi les meilleurs
vous n'avez droit à rien vous ne le
compenser par rien alors que dans une
société comme la nôtre avec ces
injustices on peut compenser par plein
de choses on peut aider sa famille qui a
eu moins de chance que vous on peut
amener ses copains on peut les aider
on peut compenser ces manques vous
parliez des classes populaires qui n'ont
pas forcément les codes culturels pour
réussir oui et non on peut dire
aujourd'hui que le 93 département dont
vous êtes issue a eu beaucoup plus
d'influencé culturellement sur le 92 ce
département le plus riche de france que
le confrère aujourd'hui dans le 92 tous
les jeunes écoutent la musique qui est
produite par les gens du 93 etc et adore
les humoristes les acteurs qui sortent
du 93 ils ont pu compenser peut-être
leur déficit culturel au sens
traditionnel du terme par de l'humour de
l'entrain de l'énergie de la débrouille
et c'est au fond est-ce que ça n'est pas
réduire considérablement que de dire
l'ascenseur social est en panne il ya
moins d'enfants d'ouvriers ou d'enfants
issus de l'immigration dans les grandes
écoles donc ils sont conduites contact
condamné au fond a échoué non beaucoup
réussissent même dans les mêmes dans les
dents avec des études traditionnelles et
puis sinon compense par une créativité
une énergie une vitalité que parfois les
enfants de la bourgeoisie non plus ou en
moins
oui mais enfin déjà moi je me méfie
alors de des gens qui ont réussi comme
ça que l'on met en avant et c'est
regarder le global
c'est vrai que le 93 à une vraie
identité culturelle
vestimentaire tout qui a été copié et
c'est une très bonne chose et maintenant
quand on regarde les faits concrets des
gens qui vivent là bas parce qu'il n'y a
pas dans 93 tout le monde n'est pas joey
starr dans 93 tout le monde n'est pas
une batte et et même si elle bat p et
joey starr band 93 et c'est appréciable
mais vous allez quand même une grosse
partie des gens du 93 qui sont des
infirmières des caissiers de
supermarchés des employés des
fonctionnaires de catégorie b
il ya plus de ces catégories là que des
traders chez hsbc disons le clairement
un vous regardez à la courneuve ya 70%
de la population qui sont des catégories
b ou c fonctionnaires ou employés
ouvriers et ces gens là en fait
qu'est-ce qui se passe eh ben vous
regardez pour les enfants deux de ses
ouvriers dans le lycée où j'étais c'est
alice et 40% des parents d'élèves vivent
sous le seuil de pauvreté
d'accord donc l'éducation devrait être
un moteur et un ascenseur social pour
ces jeunes
et qu'est-ce qui se passe eh ben on a
supprimé les cours du soir parce qu'on a
plus de moyens
blanc caire fait des économies qu'est-ce
qu'on a créé d'autres on a passé les
classes de 28 à 35 voiliers de 28 à 35
il ya moins d'argent pour les loisirs
parce qu'il ya des économies sur des
collectivités taurian il ya moins
d'argent sur les crèches il ya moins
d'argent pour les cantines et donc la
voie est très bien qu il y a dès le
départ une inégalité des chances
ce sont des populations plus pauvres est
plutôt que de leur donner des moyens
pour qu'ils réussissent en leur retire
des moyens et donc on offre finalement à
ces gens là qui sont la moyenne comme
moi qu'il faut des études qui vont pas
être dmp qui vont pas être des joey
starr qui vont faire les études et qui
essaie de s'en sortir
et bien dès le départ on leur offre
moins de moyens pour les condamnés à
devenir ce que j'ai dit moi cette espèce
demandeur ou hubert pour aller chercher
des libéraux pour aller se servir et est
utilisée est payé comme ça au lance
pierre et à la tâche
donc ça c'est un vrai problème ça c'est
un vrai problème les économies qu'on a
fait sur des collectivités doria
territoriales ont créé des inégalités
énormes surtout chez les populations les
plus pauvres et la crise du connaugh
coronavirus a révélé ça où on a vu qu'il
y avait des familles qui souffraient de
la faim dans le temps le 93 et qu'on a
vu que tout le 93 le département le plus
jeune et celui qui a eu le plus de
surmortalité
pourquoi parce que c'est la population
qui était le plus exposé
pourquoi il était le plus exposé parce
que c'était la population qui
travaillait c'est la population qui
était représenté dans le secteur médical
qui étaient représentées dans le
personnel déçu des supermarchés c'est
aussi une population qui vit dans des
logements plus insalubres enquêtant sur
population par rapport au logement et
donc le virus a beaucoup plus transmis
et donc on s'est rendu compte que
finalement les inégalités et ça s'est
vérifié aussi dans d'autres pays que les
inégalités tué et rendez les populations
plus vulnérables face aux coronavirus
alors que coronavirus frappe
essentiellement des personnes plutôt
âgées au départ donc non il y avait
toujours une possibilité de s'en sortir
mais les enfants des banlieues mais y
compris des territoires cours avec des
sacs de sable au pied et en plus je
dirais on leur met en plus des courses
d'obstacles
alors que certains sont suspendues par
des fils comme dans les films de kung fu
voyez les parents les suspentes par des
fils et des qui font un pas ils font des
pas de 300 400 m comme dans les films de
kung fu on est suspendu par des films
c'est ça la réalité des faits c'est que
personne de cours de la même façon
certains en sont désavantagés et
d'autres sont très avantagés thomas
porcher vous avez intitulé votre livre
les les délaissés ils sont délaissés
depuis quand ça commence quand pour vous
ce moment où tout à coup votre blog
divisé va être commencé à être sacrifiés
par par les gouvernants parce que c'est
comme ça que vous le voyez il ya les a
sacrifiés
on les a pas seulement de laisser ou les
a sacrifiés parfois des cinq ans dans ce
camp mais ça commence
bon il ya toujours eu des inégalités et
elles ont fortement augmenté à partir
des années 80 vous savez la croissance
économique qu'on a eu à l'après guerre
c'est-à-dire dès 1950 à 1970 c'est une
croissance économique qui était beaucoup
plus redistributive est en fait la
majorité de la population récupérer une
plus grosse partie de la croissance que
que le 1 ou 5 % et puis à part des
années 80 il ya eu un tournant
le libéralisme le tout tournant thatcher
reagan qui a été appliquée pleinement au
royaume-uni aux etats-unis qui a été
appliquée aussi en france peut-être en
allant un peu moins loin même si
emmanuel macron est en train de
rattraper ça et qui a fait que voilà les
1% ont récupéré une plus grosse part du
gâteau et le reste de la population lui
a vécu ce que aujourd'hui les
économistes libéraux qui ont défendu ce
modèle à peine l'austérité salariale et
vous avez une grosse partie de la
population qui s'appauvrit
donc moi je dirais que les 40 années ont
été vraiment un coup très fort porté
avec l'austérité la financiarisation et
la mondialisation aux classes populaires
et donc ces gens là sont devenus des
meubles aujourd'hui que l'on ajuste
finalement en fonction des besoins du du
patronat ou d un pour cent des
actionnaires et ainsi de suite qu'on a
juste pour que ces gens puissent garder
toujours leur leur part de profit ou
leurs dividendes et les autres on les
bouge en fonction de la conjoncture et
c'est ce qui se passe et ce qui est
dingue c'est que là dessus sur et je
regarde la dernière crise de 2008 sur la
dernière crise 2008
il ya des tonnes d'argent public qui ont
été sauvés les banques des tonnes
d'agents publics qui ont soutenu
l'activité et on a fait croire aux
populations qu'il avait vécu au dessus
de leurs moyens depuis beaucoup d'années
et c'est là dessus que le patronat a
réussi à négocier des doigts travail et
que le 1% les puristes a réussi à
baisser sa fiscalité
on a quand même donné ces dernières
années 4 milliards au 1% les plus riches
qui détiennent déjà 25% du patrimoine
donc vous voyez et quand on gagne c'est
4 milliards qu'est-ce qu'on
c'est en coupe de l'autre côté dans les
services publics et le service public
c'est quoi c'est patrimoine du pauvre
donc ce que l'on donne à des gens quand
il ya une baisse de qualité ce que l'on
donne à certains ont leurs proies
toujours de l'autre côté
au même moment les classes populaires
dans les années quatre-vingt seize de
voter pour le parti communiste et
commencent à voter pour le front
national
là aussi ça joue c'est à dire que avant
peut-être que l'économie et redistribuer
davantage aux classes populaires
évidemment qu'elle le faisait mais aussi
parce qu'il y avait un parti communiste
fort il y avait une alternative quelque
part qui pouvait faire peur c'était
l'union soviétique c'était c'était le
parti communiste à partir du moment où
il n'y a plus cette crainte
évidemment et où en plus le peuple au
fond ne vote plus d'un seul homme comme
il a pu le faire en partie pour le parti
communiste
évidemment ça change tout la lutte
politique la lutte des classes on a
l'impression qu'elle s'arrête à ce
moment là oui c'est vrai que le croit y
avait la menace de l'urss et beaucoup
d'intellectuels français qui regardaient
de ce côté là on s'en souvient il
fallait développer ce qu'on appelle un
capitalisme de la séduction c'est à dire
un capitalisme qui plaisent finalement
même aux classes peau aux classes
populaires
quand il ya eu d'effondrement de l'urss
on est rentré dans la période où il n'y
avait plus d'alternative sauf le
libéralisme la mondialisation heureuse
et etc etc
mais on se rend compte aujourd'hui que
ce qu'on nous avait promis finalement
n'a pas eu lieu et qui est les
inégalités augmentent et qui a une
partie de la population qui n'iront
trouve pas son compte que probablement
les enfants d'ouvriers aujourd'hui
seront plus pauvres que leurs parents
qu'aujourd'hui en france dans les hauts
de france ou dans le grand est
et ben on est plus pauvre qu'il y a dix
ans qu'en grèce on est plus pauvre qu'il
ya dix ans qu'en espagne c'est pareil
qu'en italie et c'est pareil et donc
soit on continue comme ça
soit on se dit qu'il faut changer de
système et là on a eu la crise de 2008
vous savez normalement à chaque crise
vous avez un changement du mode de
régulation de l'économie et balla n'y a
pas eu de changement on est encore plus
loin par la logique libérale
là vous avez la crise du cornât virus et
quand je vois les premières sorties du
patronat ou des instituts financiers
comme l'institut montaigne par par le
patronat eh ben on sent qu'on va aller
encore plus loin dans cette logique on
va faire supporter finalement tous les
ajustements à la majorité de la
population et je pense que là l'occasion
mais c'est très difficile parce cette
population avec le confinement de
manière difficile 1 si je pense que là
c'est l'occasion aujourd'hui en crise de
dire c'est fini ce sera pas du tout la
même chose qu'avant il faut absolument
changer de mode de régulation il faut
faire en sorte qu'aujourd'hui on est un
système qui soit moins inégalitaire au
départ il n'y a pas que la correction
des inégalités via la fiscalité moins
inégalitaire au départ avec des salaires
plus élevés avec un état social beaucoup
plus développée avec un état stratège
qui qui voit la rock'n relocaliser une
partie des emplois développe des
activités qui se délocalise pas et qui
pourrait en plus aider la transition
énergétique pour changer les choses si
on prend pas un grand virage et qu'on
continue comme avant
moi j'ai très peur que dans dix ans on
se retrouve dans une situation pire que
celle que nous avions vécue avant la
crise du coin d'un virus qui est une
situation quand même qui était déjà très
difficile à vivre pour la majorité de la
population nous l'avons vu en france
avec et gilet jaune mais nous l'avons vu
partout dans le monde avec des
populations qui sont extrêmement pauvres
sa leaf aux états unis vous avec 30
oui nous interrompt thomas porcher ont
fait une pause on se retrouve juste
appelé
[Musique]
on reprend le cours de notre
conversation avec l'économiste thomas
porcher qui publie les délaissés chez
fayard c'est sous titré comment
transformer un bloc divisé en force
majoritaire c'est un livre sur la lutte
des classes alors d'un côté dans ce bloc
divisé vous identifier quatre groupes
celui que vous appelez les villes et
jaune il ya les habitants des banlieues
il ya les agriculteurs et il ya les
cadres des classes et alors on va les
regarder un peu comment sont pas les
jets les jaunes ils sont victimes
de quoi les gilet jaune pour vous en
fait quand j'ai fait la catégorie les
gilet jaune je me suis dit c'est les
habitants principalement parce que
certains appellent la france
périphérique
ils sont victimes comme je les dis de la
fermeture des usines ces trente
dernières années de l'austérité
budgétaire qui a fermé des services
publics de la financiarisation qui a
augmenté
finalement que la délocalisation de ces
entreprises ya la mondialisation et qui
a fait que vous avez aujourd'hui
certaines régions où vous avez des taux
de chômage qui ont explosé et on
n'arrive plus finalement à offrir des
débouchés à ses populations
ce qui est dingue c'est que en fait
quand les entreprises ont commencé à
partir avec la mondialisation et la
financiarisation
normalement l'état aurait dû intervenir
à ce moment là pour contrebalancer ces
effets négatifs de la mondialisation
mais en fait l'état à ce moment là s'est
désengagé de de ces territoires et donc
on a laissé des populations comme ça
survivre parce que vous avez parfois des
populations dans ces endroits là et je
montre dans un des chapitres avec
l'exemple de la raffinerie de petroplus
vous avez des communes qui vivent
entièrement finalement qui dépendent
entièrement de l'activité de manière
directe ou indirecte de la raffinerie
donc quand sa ferme vous laisser les
populations comme ça et le discours qui
a été offert à ces populations
c'est un discours sur voilà l'individu
il faut que vous formiez mieux alors que
jamais les gens qu'ils ont employé les
ont formés
jamais ils les ont plutôt spécialisés
sont des tâches propres pour qu'ils
soient plus efficaces de la bête formés
à ce qui se dit puisse changer d'emploi
et la deuxième chose c'est on leur parle
d'eux
militer et là c'est extrêmement
humiliant parce qu'on vous êtes depuis
30 ans dans une la même usine que vous
avez fait un prêt de 20 ans 25 ans pour
vous acheter une maison et qu'on vous
vend après la question de la mobilité
alors que tout a été fait pour vous ne
soyez pas mobile il voulait dit plutôt
spécialisés sur une seule tâche dans
l'entreprise et ben effectivement ça
reste un discours moi je trouve qui est
extrêmement hypocrite donc ces gens ont
vécu de plein fouet pendant 30 ans
mondialisation financiarisation et
austérité où on a laissé ses territoires
comme ça mais laisser seuls c'est tout
et on s'est concentré sur des grandes
villes autour qui devait prendre les
meilleurs de ces territoires qui font
des études et ainsi de suite
et laisser les autres et quand les
usines et dans ces grandes villes il ya
les cités de banlieue alors les cités de
banlieue elles sont elles ont été
sacrifiés où elles sont discriminés
celle ci mais la banlieue était la même
chose c'est-à-dire que les cités au
début où ont été faites souvent pour
loger les ouvriers étaient des usines au
lait 3000 a été construite en partie
pour loger les entreprises les maisons
et les ouvriers de tsr voiliers et de
deux usines d'aulnay et quand ces usines
commence à délocaliser ou à fermer
eh ben vous avez les taux de chômage qui
explose dans ces cités et les problèmes
après qu'on peut connaître mais vous
avez parfois des taux de pauvreté qui
vont grimper les taux de chômage qui ont
grimpé à sa portée qui vont grimper à
des niveaux assez impressionnant et donc
c'est ça a vécu finalement le même
historique
sauf que la banlieue à un peu plus
d'opportunités de trouver des emplois
mais attention ce sont des emplois
souvent mal rémunérés
il faut être très flexibles et ainsi de
suite parce qu'elles vivent près des
centre villes et dans les centres-villes
vous avez besoin d'une main d'oeuvre
corvéable à merci qui a été poussé au
maximum avec l'arrivée d'une peur et de
des libéraux etc qui peut puiser dans
cette main d'oeuvre et vous avez même
macron qu'il avait dit très honnêtement
je me souviens mois quand il était
candidat il était à mediapart il avait
dit mais moi je pourrai alors offrir aux
jeunes de banlieue il avait même dit ni
vous ni moi à mediapart n'est pas que
mediapart de m'offrir des jeunes aux
jeunes de banlieue il dit donc qu'est-ce
que vous voulez que je dise à hubert si
un jeune de stains préfère les
trahissent hubert plutôt quelques
dealers saperait grosso modo ça qu'il
avait dit je le cite dans le livre par
ailleurs
donc voyez on se déplace
opportunité la seule possibilité pour
ces jeunes là eh ben c'est d'avoir
d'être chauffeur gilbert des libéraux
avec cette fausse idée que vous
commencez pas comme ça et quand tu
travailles en cognant du courage vous
allez finir très haut
c'est extrêmement rare et des exemples
qui le monde parfois mais globalement
c'est extrêmement rare nous ce que l'on
demande en fait ce que demandent les
jeunes de banlieue ce que c'est qu'ils
aient les mêmes conditions et ils n'ont
pas du tout les mêmes conditions
ils ont moins de services publics dans
des jouets dit avec l'éducation des
moyens en moins et ainsi de suite
ce qui fait qu'ils partent avec des
capitales culturelles qui n'est pas
adaptée à la capitale culturelle qui
n'est pas adaptée à la méritocratie de
l'éducation et les parts avec des moyens
dans les services publics qui sont
moindres donc dans ces conditions quand
ils réussissent et ben c'est qu'ils ont
été beaucoup plus forts que ceux qui
sont suspendues par des fils comme je le
disais ok pour les gilet jaune ok pour
les jeunes de banlieue maintenant les
agriculteurs les agriculteurs alors ils
sont victimes de quoi et comment vous
allez faire pour trouver un ennemi
commun un adversaire commun à à tous ces
gens mais là mais regardez un
agriculteur il est victime de la
mondialisation de la financiarisation et
l'austérité je le décris très bien dans
le livre pourquoi de la mondialisation
parce qu'aujourd'hui notre agriculture
elle est à l'export alors ça ça loos
alors ça ça leur allait à un moment
parce qu'ils trouvaient des débouchés en
moyen-orient était très content en
afrique il a hissé très content pour eux
il n'y avait pas de limites sauf
qu'aujourd'hui sont concurrencés par
l'agriculture brésilienne l'agriculteur
l'agriculture des pays de l'est et donc
ils ont de plus en plus de mal à tenir
ce qu'on appelle la compétitivité
internationale
ça c'est la première des choses la
deuxième des choses c'est que
aujourd'hui le prix d'une marchandise de
prix un agriculteur qui produit du blé
c'est plus lui qui détermine le prix de
son blé ce sont les marchés financiers
via des paniers de biens comme j'avais
dit le goldman sachs commodity index qui
relié au pétrole au dollar au yen et
c'est ce sont eux aujourd'hui qu'il
détermine les prix donc quitté la salle
juste je fais de se souvenir que jusque
dans les années 90 les les prix sont
sont régulés ils sont garantis aux
producteurs et qu'à partir des années 90
ils vont être soumis aux lois du marché
comme les prix d'à peu près tout le
reste 1
l'agriculture avait un statut spécial
comme aujourd'hui encore le livre en a
un par exemple oui tout à fait tout à
fait sauf que l'agriculture a quand même
une utilité 1
on l'a vu encore une fois pendant cette
crise a heureusement que les apiculteurs
était là au front pour qu'on puisse
avoir des mains des denrées alimentaires
c'est quand même quelque chose de
spécifique à l'agriculture
or là aujourd'hui l'agriculture est
extrêmement financiarisé et ce qui
détermine les prix sur la marché sur le
marché financier c'est des grandes
banques comme goldman sachs avec leur
goldman sachs commodity index ou
d'autres banques
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui un producteur
de lait par exemple il ne maîtrise pas
le prix de son lait et c'est très grave
c'est l'air surpris et extrêmement
volatile
c'est dire si demain un avait un acquis
culteurs du lait en bretagne il veut
investir
il investit en fonction de ce qu'ils
espèrent gagner ce qu'il espère gagner
dépend du prix auquel il vend son lait
mais comme ils n'arrivent pas à avoir
une visibilité de quelques mois sur le
prix du lait c'est extrêmement compliqué
d'investir donc il ya beaucoup de gens
qui ont fait le pari qu'ils ont investi
et puis les prix ont chuté avec la crise
2008 ou avec l'arrivée de concurrents
comme la chine ce qui fait que ces gens
là se retrouvent ruinés et voiliers et
donc la mondialisation la
financiarisation a frappé ces catégories
là d'une différentes façons que la vigie
les jaunes et les habitants des
banlieues qui ont finalement un peu le
même type qui fakih qui ont été frappés
par le modèle de la paix de la même
façon mais les autres aussi sont quand
même frappé par ce modèle économique est
encore une fois les agriculteurs qui
vivent majoritairement en province ont
aussi été frappée par l'austérité
budgétaire
donc même si à moins de points communs
dans la manière dont ils ont été frappés
c'est pas des usines qui ont fermé c'est
le modèle mondialisation
financiarisation qui les affectent
aujourd'hui et ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui nos agriculteurs sont
extrêmement compétitif en fait ils ont
fait des progrès énormes en termes de
compétitivité
mais ils sont plus pauvres voilà est ce
qui explique les suicides que l'on
connaît donc ces gens là aujourd'hui
doivent être conscients que c'est
ils ne sont pas dans cette situation à
cause un habitant de banlieue ou à cause
d'un autre travailleur d'un
fonctionnaire ou ainsi de suite qui sans
cette condition là à cause d'un modèle
quand on voit ce tracteur qui est
derrière moi on en a vu beaucoup à paris
c'était avant la crise du co2 rona virus
ça semble une éternité qu'on a vu ces
tracteurs arrivée sur le périphérique à
paris avec des pancartes comme celle ci
et je pense pas que les cadres qui sont
votre quatrième groupe de votre de ce
blog divisée je pense pas que les cadres
qui étaient avec leur voiture et qui
voyait cette pancarte avec des tracteurs
se sont dit me parle à moi aussi on a le
même on a les mêmes problèmes
on a les mêmes adversaires or c'est ce
que vous dites dans votre livre au fond
le cadre celui qui prend le métro le
matin pour aller à son travail au fond
est dans une situation assez proche de
celle de ce paysan en colère qui
défilaient sur les champs elysées ou des
gilet jaune qui alors le paysan collet
resté sur le périphérique ou des gels et
jaune qui a défilé sur les
champs-elysées le cadre il a les mêmes
ennemis les mêmes adversaires pour vous
oui oui le cadre alors même si dans son
vote
on a bien vu il voit tu es plutôt
majoritairement macron mais il ya une
grosse partie comme il ya une petite
partie des cadres dans des domaines par
exemple la tech ou faut être très
qualifiés dans certains domaines qui eux
sont encore des élites de la
modélisation vous avez une grosse partie
des cadres aujourd'hui qu'ils sont en
concurrence avec des pays les pays de
l'est ou avec l'inde dans l'audit ou
ailleurs qui ont des salaires qui encore
une fois je les dis hein
si on prend en compte si on tient compte
de l'inflation qui n'ont pas augmenté
depuis 15 ans et quand on voit comment
on augmente les prix de l'immobilier
vous avez une grosse partie des cadres
il commence à 2200 euros ils prennent
leur première à parties n'ont pas de
patrimoine ip 800 euros ça me prayssas
voyez ils vivent dans un mètre carré
alors allez leur dire ce sont des grands
gagnants des élites nationales des
élites mondialisées dans leur vie de
tous les jours et s'en aperçoivent pas
voyez et ils subissent encore une fois
le stress où on leur dit de faire du
chiffre on les augmente - ual a en
période de crise va falloir que ce soit
qu'il soit là justement pour que
l'actionnaire puisse garder la part du
profit qui le récupère et ainsi de suite
donc ces gens là certes ils ne vivent
pas la mondialisation et la
financiarisation et l'austérité de la
même manière que un gilet jaune qu'un
habitants des banlieues ou cannes
agriculteurs mais il la subit quand même
et donc ils feraient mieux de se ranger
du côté du reste que de se ranger du
côté des 1 % parce qu'aujourd'hui vous
regardez mes vous regardez un mois j'ai
un ami il vit dans vingt mètres carrés a
pas
il est tombé l'autre fois dans sa
trottinette alors quand on le voit sans
papiers on peut dire que c'est un calme
c'est très bien il a été à l'hôpital est
attendu douze heures pour ce cancer
recoudre baladant sa vie vous voyez très
bien qu'il est victime de la
financiarisation de l'élection et
l'austérité budgétaire même si sur le
papier il a l'air d'être on va dire que
tu as fait cinq ans d'études
tu es en haut tu es dans les 30 % les
mieux payés ben ouais mais de même dans
les 30 % les mieux payés et battu
vésubie un niveau différent tu es
impactés par ce modèle économique donc
tu as intérêt plutôt à le remettre en
cause mais une grosse partie des cadres
ont pris conscience de ça aujourd'hui
peut-être pas au point de mai encore que
une grosse partie des cadres ont pris
conscience que ils étaient plutôt des
victimes et on le voit bien dans les
études
tout était fait sur le locaux le moral
des salariés etc qu'ils se rendent
compte qu'ils sont plutôt victimes et
qu'on leur demande d'être de plus en
plus compétitif parce qu'il ya des
salariés à deux heures de vol qui savent
faire la même chose qu'eux qui parlent
aujourd'hui anglais et qui demande deux
fois moins et c'est pour ça qu'on
développe tout un tas de séminaires de
bien-être de yoga de communication de
machin pour essayer de dire voilà où
vous vous soyez mieux dans le travail le
problème c'est vous alors que le
problème c'est pas eu en fait c'est le
problème structurel c'est que leur
situation se dégrade comme les employés
dans les années 80 et qu'ils auront
probablement une grosse partie le sort
des employés et là je parle vraiment des
cadres moyens à ceux qui ont fait pas
plus 5
je parle pas du 1 % des cadres du 5 %
des cartes qui sont dans des filières
extrêmement compétitive dans la tête qui
sont surqualifiés qui eux bénéficient
encore plein pot de la croissance
économique et de la mondialisation
on voit bien que l'ennemi de tout le
monde à vos yeux
thomas c'est la mondialisation donc
c'est la concurrence internationale
et pourtant il fut un temps où il y
avait moins de concurrence
internationale et pour cause il y avait
un petit bloc de pays riches dont nous
faisions partie puis avec le bloc
communiste qui étaient très pauvres mais
qui n'entraient pas en compétition avec
nous et puis le reste ça s'appelait le
tiers-monde et le tiers-monde pas où on
allait grum ans ont pillé leurs matières
premières mais dans la fabrication dans
la production il n'existait pas
d'ailleurs il ne consommait pas ils
produisaient très peu il était très
pauvre
vous devriez vous réjouir enfin il me
semble avec vos idées de savoir qu'une
bonne partie de la planète est sorti de
ça et que au fond aujourd'hui elle
demande à son tour des parts de marché
elle aussi fabrique des choses et peut
entrer en compétition avec nous or vous
avez l'air de le regretter peut-être que
vous voudriez qu'on retourne à l'époque
où au fond on était entre quelques pays
capitaliste on se partageait le monde
et puis les autres au fond on s'en
occupe air et chaque fois qu'il y avait
une famine
aujourd'hui c'est vrai ils fabriquent
des choses comme nous et parfois aussi
bien et parfois mieux est parfois plus
rapidement alors déjà la première chose
et je le rappelle d'ailleurs dans mon
livre une grosse partie où je parle de
l'immigration et je parle justement du
développement des pays pauvres et dans
mon premier livre j'en parlais aussi eu
l'idée en fait que le libre-échange et
est une arme qui avaient été imposées
aux pays pauvres justement pour les
soumettre
et c'est une réalité c'est à dire que
vous aviez un certain nombre de pays
pauvres qui avaient des meilleurs taux
de croissance et de développement avant
qu'on leur impose finalement un système
qui était aussi le site même de la
mondialisation
vous savez aujourd'hui quand vous êtes
un pays comme la france au ministère des
finances vous prenez votre téléphone
vous appelez les marchés financiers on
vous prête de l'argent à des taux
d'intérêt négatifs et donc vous pouvez
investir là où vous voulez quand vous
êtes un pays pauvre
moi j'ai travaillé au congo en afrique
vous êtes les ministères des finances
vous appelez les marchés financiers pour
emprunter et les marchés financiers vont
raccroche au nez donc vous êtes obligés
d'aller voir le fmi qui est le prêteur
de dernier recours
or le fmi quand ils vous prête de
l'argent il vous impose un programme
parce qu'il dit vous n'avez pas de
garantie donc vous impose un programme
et ce programme c'est souvent ceux
spécialisés dans les ressources à
l'export dont dans la mondialisation
c'est pour ça que le pays comme le congo
je travaillais 98 % de ses exportations
c'est un produit le pétrole d'accord qui
sert d'autres pays qui ne le sert pas
lui voyez alors que l'agriculture est à
4% des potentialités et que la investir
de l'agriculture c'est pas possible pour
le fmi parce que c'est pas à l'export et
ça sert à rien alors que les gens fin là
bas et qu'ils auraient peut-être besoin
d'une meilleure avec une agriculture que
d'exporter du pétrole
donc vous voyez il ya eu un modèle qui a
été imposé à ces pays là mais
effectivement effectivement dans ce
modèle qui a été imposé à ces pays là
vous avez certains pays qui ont réussi à
tirer leur épingle du jeu en premier jus
en premier lieu ce sont les ce qu'on
appelle les nouveaux pays industrialisés
d'asie la corée hong kong taiwan
singapour puis après il ya eu certains
pays comme le brésil la chine qui ont
tiré un peu plus tard épingle du jeu
mais je ne suis pas d'accord avec vous
quand vous dites que tros partie de la
population est sorti de la pauvreté
vous avez une petite partie qui s'est
enrichie énormément et qui a qui peut
concurrencer on attend très rapide des
familles qui ont mis des siècles à
s'enrichir sur des principes parfois un
peu bizarre dans les pays occidentaux un
disque la page et de commutation ainsi
de suite donc vous avez effectivement
les pneus des populations se soigner
dans les pays pauvres qui sont enrichis
très rapidement et qu'ils peuvent
concurrencer cela nous avait une grosse
partie de la population qui reste
majoritairement pauvre et c'est pas
parce qu'elles ne vivent plus avec un
dollar par jour et qu'elles vivent avec
deux dollars et donc statistiquement ils
ne font plus partie des pauvres qu'elles
sont riches
elles sont toujours pauvres sauf que les
d'avoir un dollar est long
de dollars et quand vous regardez
aujourd'hui dans les pays qui ont réduit
massivement leur pauvreté
vous avez une grosse partie de la
population qui effectivement le gameplay
de la mégane iii 4 dollars mais qui
reste très pauvre qui n'a pas d'accès à
l'eau potable qui n'a pas de toilettes
qui souffrent encore de la faim et
institutes et ainsi de suite donc pareil
il faudrait avoir quand même une vraie
vision des apports de la mondialisation
qui ont en réalité servi moi je pense
qu'une petite partie de la population y
compris dans ces pays et pas l'ensemble
de la population et vous regardez ces
pays sont encore soumis même quand ils
ont un plan social a développées sont
encore très soumis aux pays occidentaux
à part encore une fois sans les 200 pays
190 pays qui devait avoir dans le monde
vous avez peut-être quatre cinq six la
corée du sud dans un parti qui ont tiré
leur épingle du jeu et kiki new
challenge complètement 1
la corée du sud par exemple samsung en
europe n'a pas d'équivalent samsung donc
c'est samsung et apple qui se partagent
le monde et nous on est au milieu en
arrière fait ça c'est une eau qui
derrière nous mais globalement vous avez
beaucoup de pays pense à l'afrique qui
sont restés pauvres et la situation n'a
absolument pas changé pour ces pays avec
la mondialisation
vous pensez que également qu'il faut
sauver les ré les services publics
c'est une des ce que vous conseillez à
ce bloc diviser pour devenir une force
majoritaire c'est qui le qui le sauve
les services publics donc c'est la fin
des restrictions budgétaires et et puis
c'est aussi la fin d'une certaine
manière je crois que vous appelez de vos
voeux de la concurrence du public et du
privé
oui oui moi je ne pose pas le privé le
public en fait comme certains le font et
moi je pense que emmanuel macron par
exemple a opposé très fortement privés
et publics
on se souvient qu'ils disent et qui ne
l'est pas le modèle social français que
statut de fonctionnaire n'avait pas lieu
d'être
donc il oppose vraiment le privé public
qui est très idiot parce qu'en réalité
le public et le privé vont ensemble moi
je suis pour une économie mixte
je pense que vous savez la france a tiré
beaucoup d'entrepreneurs étrangers pas
parce qu'elle avait une fiscalité plus
avantageuse ça c'est macron qu'à
rajouter ça et parce qu'elle avait des
infrastructures très développée
notamment infrastructures de transport
et de santé qui est telle que les gens
jugés efficaces
donc quand tous installés en france on
savait qu'on avait une santé et pour
gratuite et qu'on avait et de
l'éducation de bons niveaux gratuits et
des belles infrastructures de transport
c'était ça au début qui a tiré les
entrepreneurs s'étaient pas que là
qualité comme va coincer à croire
d'ailleurs les pleins de pays pauvres
qui pèse partie qualité personne ne
vient vous avez plein d'endroits en
france on a fait des zones franches et
personne ne veut venir non plus ce qui
faisait qu'on venait chez nous c'était
pour des infrastructures majoritairement
public donc le public et le privé
ce que ce s'autoalimente en réalité ne
s'oppose pas et moi ce que je veux c'est
que j'ai une sphère privée effectivement
qui est importante mais aussi une sphère
publique
les transports éducation qui réglemente
la sphère privée mais qu'ils
investissent également la transition
énergétique pour moi elle se fait sur du
public et du privé pas que ce soit du
privé parce que sinon ça sera jamais et
pas que ce soit du public parce qu'il ya
des entreprises privées qui fonctionne
bien mais avec une réglementation du
secteur public au rôle en lui ce qui se
passe en europe et c'est ce qui se passe
dans les dernier quinquennat qu'on a eu
c'est qu'il faut casser la sphère
publique et la laisser à la sphère
privée
on l'a vu avec la vente des dp avec le
fait de libéraliser d'ouvrir à la
concurrence des mgf plutôt que d'en
faire un bras armé la transition
énergétique
on préfère à l'ouvrir à la concurrence
voilà la privatiser j'avais bien rangées
bien pas vous savez bien que c'est un
c'est l'union européenne ce sont nos
accords avec l'union européenne qui nous
oblige à ouvrir la concurrence pour le
train parce qu'il ya la libre
circulation des entreprises des capitaux
et des gens dans l'union européenne et
que au nom de quoi est ce que la france
voudrait préserver son monopole sur le
système ferroviaire français
il faut ouvrir lui dit-on à la
concurrence comme on a ouvert à la
concurrence le téléphone avant il y
avait que france télécom qui pouvait
vendre du téléphone mais maintenant il
ya tout le monde qui peut vendre du
téléphone et on a fait ça à peu près
dans tous les domaines et m'attend ça
arrive et laisse sncf est frappé comme
les autres j'ai l'impression que vous
dans votre programme entre guillemets si
on peut parler de programme
vous voudriez au fond vous seriez
obligés de mettre fin à l europe parce
que vous voudriez limiter
considérablement la concurrence et
notamment la concurrence internationale
vous voudriez limiter considérablement
la concurrence entre le public et le
privé et que maintenir des monopoles
comme celui de la sncf par semaine par
exemple
donc c'est la fin de l'europe en gros il
vous le dit d'ailleurs vous dites il
faut être prêt à sortir faire comme le
général de gaulle à un moment qu'ils
aiment et qui a fait pendant quelques
mois bloquer les institutions ne fasse
ça n'avait rien à voir à l'époque on
était beaucoup moins intégrés et que de
mick mans politiquement avec les autres
pays d'europe au jeu pour je pense pas
que ce soit une question d'intégration
et je pense que c'est une question de
savoir établir un rapport de force le
général de gaulle dans son comportement
savait le faire mais margaret thatcher
qui était libéral a su le faire aussi en
son temps quand elle a voulu baisser ce
que ce que finançait le royaume uni à
l'europe donc ça dépend vraiment de qui
est prêt à mettre ce rapport de force
et moi je pense que quand je vois dans
le livre je parle d'un sondage qui avait
été fait sur 1000 jeunes qui étaient
assez intéressant où les jeunes disaient
que voilà l'europe n'était pas une
démocratie où la majorité disait qu'il
voulait que l'europe lutte contre les
inégalités et contre le climat avec eux
80 % se disaient que l'europe n'était
pas à la hauteur et que vous aviez
derrière une table ronde avec des
journalistes du monde du temps des
grands journalistes qui expliquait
constamment à ces jeunes là qu'il
n'avait pas compris ce qu'était l'europe
or moi je trouvais qu'ils avaient une
lucidité impressionnante parce que oui
l'europe n'est pas une démocratie
les grecs ont voté non leur a dit oui
nous nous avons et non à la constitution
nous a dit oui aussi vous avez tout un
tas de d'une matrice institutionnel qui
établit des déréglementations sur les
déficits année donc il limite la
démocratie et vous regardez sur le
climat l'europe absolument pas à la
hauteur elle fait des grandes leçons de
morale mais qu'aucun pays de l'union
européenne n'a respecté les apps
l'accord de la coop 21 et vous regardez
sur les inégalités n'en parlons pas elle
fait tout pour les inégalités augmentent
de plus en plus donc l'europe n'est pas
du tout au niveau donc maintenant soit
on est dans le rêve et on continue à
dire que c'est génial et c'est super
parce que l'europe c'est la paix je ne
sais pas quoi etc
on dit des grandes phrases comme ça soit
on est concret et on se dit bon
plus continuer on établit un rapport de
force et je veux dire qu'aujourd'hui
santé et on n'est pas simple quand on
fait un rapport de force toujours être
prêt à sortir et je trouve que vous avez
là il ya le fait qu' aucun pays n'est
prévu un scénario de sortie pause pour
moi un problème
et moi je pense que le trésor
aujourd'hui où bercy devraient bosser
sur des scénarios de sortie parce
qu'aujourd'hui les seuls qui bossent sur
les scénarios de sortie ce sont les
américains c'est krugman s'est stiglitz
etc
mais il faudrait qu aujourd'hui des
français au ministère travaille sur un
scénario de sortie parce que sur la
passe par une sortie un moment voilà on
pourra pas établir un rapport de force
mais encore une fois aujourd'hui macro
n'a pas établi de rapport de force parce
qu'ils pensent que l'europe fonctionne
bien et je pense qu'on serait même pas
dans l'europe il doit appliquer la même
politique on n'est pas obligé d'être en
europe pour appliquer une politique
libérale
mais quand on est libéral et ben c'est
très bien l'europe appuie cette
politique là donc on est content
maintenant si on veut organiser un grand
tournant mais notamment à établir un
rapport de force est prêt à en sortir
c'est sûr c'est indéniable j'ai
l'impression après avoir lu votre livre
thomas porcher confond vous êtes comme
beaucoup j'avais une certaine nostalgie
de la france du général de gaulle et de
georges pompidou à la fois premier
ministre et président de la république
d'ailleurs une france au fond qui
respectait les équilibres byook
aujourd'hui semble-t-il les équilibres
que vous vous souhaiteriez retrouver
aujourd'hui dans une population comme la
l'autre au fond il y avait cette lutte
des classes plus équilibré à l'époque et
les ouvriers les classes populaires
obtenaient des désavantages et dans le
système de répartition des richesses au
fond était bien moins lésés et bien
moins délaissé qu'ils ne le sont
devenu depuis mai et vous seriez prêt au
fonds a pour pouvoir retrouver ça à en
finir avec l'europe si nécessaire avec
la mondialisation avec la concurrence
internationale
etc etc mais si on le faisait on se
retrouverait quoi parce qu'on est une
france aujourd'hui qui n'a plus de
sidérurgie qui n'a plus d'industrie
textile qui ne fabrique plus de
téléphone qui ne fera briller plus de
téléviseurs qui dut france qu il ya
beaucoup d industrialiser c'est un des
pays d'europe qui a le plus d
industrialiser et on fabrique plus
d'ordinateurs non plus est-ce qu'on
pourrait véritablement vivre dans dans
une france qui renfermerait ses
frontières d'une certaine manière pour
arriver à ce que vous souhaitez il faut
d'une manière ou d'une autre ferme et un
peu ses frontières j'ai pas été aussi
loin alors déjà sur la première partie
de votre question en fait sur la
nostalgie moi je ne suis pas nostalgique
parce que le monde évolue
pour moi le monde et dynamique je ne
regarde pas le passé après effectivement
il étonne économique qui a été appliquée
pendant ces années là avec un état
stratège avec le développement d'un état
social et qui a donné d'assez bons
résultats en tous les cas de meilleur
des rumeurs de résultats que ce que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui
donc cette méthode là je pars dans la
méthode économique pour moi il serait
nécessaire de l'art est appliquée et pas
de l'art est appliqué comme dans les
années 70 sous les trente glorieuses
aujourd'hui il faudrait effectivement un
état stratège qui commandent par exemple
la transition énergétique qui est très
importante donc il fasse en sorte de
faire des choix
est ce qu'on continue dans le nucléaire
est ce qu'on sorte du nucléaire quel
type de voiture on fabrique comme on
s'arrange pas qu'ils aient une vision de
long terme qu'on n'a pas aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui vous avez un ministre de
l'économie qui va aux états unis qui dit
hattestad venir alors qu'on a de
l'argent public dans nos entreprises
france nos deux constructeurs
automobiles français combat investir de
l'argent
vous avez tout et n'importe quoi le
ministre le président la république qui
va visiter toyota alors qu'on a deux
constructeurs automobiles où on a encore
de l'argent dessus par année dans
vraiment n'y a pas de vision
industrielle il ya plus de vision dans
ce pays qui a une vision en fait qui a
pour but seulement de donner des
conditions sympathique aux industriels
en fête ses dix ans le marché du travail
en baissant leurs fiscalités ya plus une
vision qu'il a réellement l'emploi oui
mais bizarrement inari n'en crée pas
tant que ça et effectivement les emplois
sont créés à l'extérieur je veux dire
les emplois vous regardez entre entre
2008 et avant la crise du coup en habit
russe vous aviez toujours
pratiquement un million d'emplois en
moins par rapport à la crise 2008
je veux dire quand macron est arrivé au
pouvoir vous aviez 1,5 million d'emplois
en moins donc c'est pas parce qu'on a
créé après trois mille emplois dans les
autobus je ne sais quoi que on a créé
des emplois voyez moi je parle de gens
regardent les chiffres au niveau
macroéconomique il force est de
constater que les emplois seront créés
quelques centaines de milliers ces
dernières années ce qui est un point
positif que la france est un miracle en
termes de création d'emplois voilà on
est loin d'avoir rattrapé notre retard
depuis la crise de 2008 donc moi
vraiment là je suis son développement et
d'un état social parce qu'il ya des
besoins mais je veux dire il ya vraiment
moi je ya des besoins il suffit de
demander aux comptes si on avait écouté
les infirmières les soignants avant la
crise du coran navires russes ils nous
avaient dit qu'ils avaient des besoins
alors il a fallu une crise pour qu'on se
rendre compte pour ses repas qu'il y
avait besoin de moyens et de personnel
l'hôpital vous allez la petite enfance
d'aller un enfant aujourd'hui vous allez
demander une place en crèche à la mairie
on vous dit a pas de place pour tout le
monde la lie à des besoins
donc qu'est-ce qu'on va faire on
augmente les places sans augmenter
l'espace personnel
c'est pas possible ça oui partout où il
ya des besoins pour des choses utiles
moi je mettrais de l'argent ça crée un
des emplois non délocalisables et ça
rend des services à une utilité sociale
or quand on donne 40 milliards aux
entreprises via lé cic une part de
responsabilité on n'est pas sûr on a du
mal à voir les emplois que ça a créé au
début c'était pas énorme à soit dit en
passant est l'utilité sociale faudra
encore m'expliquer à quoi ça sert donc
voilà donc moi je mettrais l'argent
qu'il faut là dessus et voilà mes
s'adapterait juge panos à l'institut du
judo j'adapterai ses moyens aux enjeux
du 21e siècle qui sont un état social et
plus écologique
ça c'est la première des choses est
maintenant sur la la mondialisation
effectivement il va falloir prenez la
modélisation mais le problème c'est de
se poser la question de ce qui est utile
pour nous il ya plein de pays en fait
qui qui qui qui ne sont pas qui ne sont
pas des choses qui se disent voilà moi
je vais produire thème bien c'est utile
pour moi je me lance là dessus ça ne pas
dire qu'il se remet à la mondialisation
c'est-à-dire qu'ils font en sorte de
choisir des gagnants voyez les états
unis ont choisi le digital dans les
années 80 ils ont mis des sommes énormes
que nous n'avons pas bien ils ont mis de
l'argent public
énormément voyez la silicon valley s'est
pas les entrepreneurs qu'ils ont créé
vous avez la main de l'état steve jobs
et son succès via la main de l'état
derrière
l'internet c'est d'état américain qu'il
a créée la reconnaissance vocale say de
l'état n'avait qu'un qu'il a créé
l'écran tactile c'est sûr fine sous
financement de l'état américain est
derrière vous avez un entrepreneur qui
reprend ses innovations et qui ont fait
un smartphone donc vous avez levé ou
l'exemple mais vous avez une économie
mixte public privé qui fonctionne bien
aujourd'hui il faut qu'en france on
retrouve cette vision de choisir des
gagnants et de choisir les secteurs où
on veut se développer et je trouve que
la transition énergétique en est un qui
est extrêmement important parce que
personne de la ferme
je vous arrête là thomas porcher merci
d'avoir passé toute cette émission avec
nous je rappelle que votre livre les
délaissés comment transformer un bloc
divisé en force majoritaire vient de
paraître aux éditions fayard
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]